why
so if you recall when we had begun the
civil war storyline we have talked about
how civil war frontline was going to
have some of the best storytelling out
of all the comics that were released as
part of the Civil War event and the
Civil War frontline issue number five
really kind of stands the test of that
it really kind of gives us a fantastic
set of events especially when we're
looking at the involvement of Sally
Floyd and Ben Urich and what we see as
the comic begins to open is that Ben
Urich is attempting to convince Jay
jonah Jameson and Robbie Robertson that
the Green Goblin has returned but
neither of them believe him we really
kind of see a flashback where we see the
events after Ben Urich and Green Goblin
came face to face and the Green Goblin
is really angry Norman Osborn is really
upset with Ben Urich and the Daily Bugle
about the things they had written about
him that it helped to lead to his
incarceration and we see that that the
Green Goblin really kind of indicates
not necessarily directly but indirectly
that he has plans to take vengeance
against the Daily Bugle from there we
switch to Sally Floyd and Sally Floyd is
in Chinatown and what we see is that
some individual approaches her from
behind and really kind of follows her in
talks to her now this individual says
that Sally Floyd does not know who he is
and Sally Floyd can't actually see him
but this individual really kind of gives
us a very interesting set of events
really kind of has some great guest
conversation with Sally and what we see
is that this individual tell Sally that
a story that she's going with that all
these underground superheroes are
attempting to make contact with Captain
America's team is the wrong story to go
with because Captain America doesn't
exist anymore you know that none of the
people that are part of this team that
are part of Captain America's Team exist
anymore and this is really kind of
pointing to the secret identities that
Nick Fury had given to Captain America
and daredevil and the other members of
his team that we had seen in previous
events of civil war in addition what we
see is that this individual really kind
of tells Sally Sally Floyd that that
someone out there someone who's
presumably part of shield believes that
she knows more than she does that she
does actually know how to get ahold of
Captain America and because of that
she's being followed we then see Sally
Floyd open her makeup kit and look in
her mirror and we see that someone is
standing on a rooftop monitoring her now
whether than whether or not this
individual knows that she's actually
having a conversation with the person
behind her or maybe just thinks her
actions are suspicious we don't really
know we simply know that someone is
following her and then in fact this
individual was most likely the person
that had tipped shield off to the
previous meeting that she was discovered
in that we had talked about in the
previous Civil War frontline issue
number four event from there we really
kind of see this individual individual
telling to Sally Floyd of the problem
with her story the problem with this
approach that she's taking is that she's
really kind of looking for conspiracy
were none exist that she's really kind
of taking the stance that there's got to
be some kind of hidden hand there's got
to be some kind of person from the
shadows that's manipulating all these
events and really kind of setting things
the way they are and then in fact there
is no hidden hand there is no conspiracy
and that this is simply just the
government attempting to create a bill
to really kind of or I guess passing a
bill to really kind of regulate
superheroes the time has finally come
when superhero simply just can't act of
their own accord that there has to be
some kind of rules laid down but the
problem is that shield and Iron Man and
other members who are part of the pro
registration movement are really kind of
screwing it up we see the Sally Floyd
attempts to turn around and ask this
individual more questions but he has
disappeared before she can do that what
we also see is that a kind of a switch
back I guess to Ben Urich and Ben Urich
is again continuing to attempt to
convince Jay jonah Jameson and Robbie
Robertson that Green Goblin has returned
but then we see that one of the staffers
appears and tells Jay jonah Jameson that
he's confirmed with Iron Man and other
maybe independent sources that the Green
Goblin is still locked up now we know
this is not the case of course we saw
that shield a screen goblin and a
previous comic if he was willing to play
by a new set of rules and so this is
really kind of the indication that while
previously we may have felt a little bit
sorry for Tony Stark previously we may
have looked at twenty stark and said you
know he might be in kind of a bad
situation because he's doing the best we
can
this is when we see Tony Stark really
kind of engaging in some very shady
actions really kind of engaging and some
very shady things at least that's the
presumption that we're given at this
point we don't actually know if Tony
Stark has verified the fact that Norman
Osborn is still in prison if he's really
kind of lied and made this statement but
given the fact that as far as we can
tell shield released Green Goblin this
really kind of seems to be the case now
what we see is that Ben Urich really
kind of begins to scream at J jonah
Jameson he really kind of tells J jonah
Jameson that he's a coward because he's
not willing to look further into this
whole Norman Osborn Green Goblin issue
because he's afraid of Green Goblin at
this point J jonah Jameson kind of calls
out Ben Urich and asked him if he's
finished and when Ben Urich says yes
then J jonah Jameson fires him now from
this point we switched back to Sally
Floyd and she's with her editor Neil
Crawford and Neil Crawford is really
asking if she has any sources for the
story that she is submitting and the
fact the story that she's submitting is
the very story that she was told not to
run that there is some kind of
conspiracy here that there is some kind
of hidden hand here and that these
superheroes are attempting to make
contact with Captain America's team of
course she says that none of these
superheroes are going to come forward to
verify this information and so the Daily
Bugle really just kind of has to take it
that it's absolutely true what we also
see taking place is that Eric Marshall
appears with several shield agents and
if you recall our previous videos when
we had talked about the early comics of
civil war front line and the instances
where Robbie Baldwin was in prison that
Eric Marshall was one of the shield
agents or the shield agent that had
informed him that he had a that the the
connection between his brain and his
superpowers had been lost that he was
under arrest and so on and so forth Eric
Marshall informs Sally Floyd that she
was discovered or she has been
identified as having met with
unregistered superheroes and did not
come forward and report them now Sally
Floyd and Neil Crawford really kind of
hide behind the Constitution here and
really kind of say that they have
they're really kind of exonerated from
any kind of charges on this caliber
because the Constitution provides the
press with the ability to one hide their
sources so they can maintain a free flow
of information without fear of
prosecution and to
because the freedom of the press is one
of the last bastions of a free society
but we see that Eric martial combats
this by saying that those rules don't
apply anymore what we see is that Sally
Floyd and Neil Crawford don't comply
they refuse to reveal their sources and
so Eric Marshall places Sally Floyd and
Neil Crawford under arrest for I guess
harboring unregistered superheroes or
refusing to report them and for acts of
terrorism now from here we switch to
Robbie Baldwin and she-hulk or Jennifer
Walters acting as the lawyer for Robbie
Baldwin and what we see is that Robbie
Baldwin's being transported to a new
facility and as they're moving along the
way she-hulk really kind of tells him
that this new facility it's someplace
called the negative zone now the
negative zone is a very important part
of Marvel Comics because it appears off
and on it was actually something the
first appeared and the Fantastic Four
issue number 51 in 1966 and the negative
zone is basically a parallel earth it's
another dimension and what we see is
that a massive prison has been built
inside the negative zone and the purpose
of this prison is to house all
superheroes who refused to register or
anyone who is found guilty of being an
unregistered superhero this may very
well include individuals who are
registered but for some reason have lost
their registration credentials now from
here we switch to the story of Joe we
really kind of get back into the story
of Joe and the sleeper agent a member of
the Atlantis royal family and what we
see is that Wonder Man is really kind of
filming an infomercial really kind of
filming a commercial design to inform I
guess the general community the human
population of the relationship that will
exist between superheroes and the
government in the sense that superheroes
will basically be a kind of police force
and that the fifty state initiative
which is the intention of Reed Richards
and shield and an Iron Man and the
government to have a
government-sanctioned superhero team in
all 50 states that it were really kind
of work in a way to where superheroes
will be a police force that they will be
a force for good as opposed to for the
most part vigilantes which up to this
point is how they've been perceived by
society and what we see is that once
Wonder Man gets back to
his location that he meets with shield
and shield really kind of performed some
undertand underhanded tactics here of
course they inform him about Joe and and
we learned that shield had been
monitoring Joe for several years because
Joe had gone by several aliases he had
gone by several names and that there was
just something kind of off about him
that really kind of caused red flags to
pop up on shields radar now initially
Wonder Man doesn't really see this as
something that he needs to be involved
in this really kind of something that's
below him and for the most part it is
but because of the fact that he has a
relatively unique set of powers because
of the fact that he is for the most part
and I guess exceeds the abilities that
virtually all Atlanteans possess that
shield really kind of blacks me a black
males him into investigating Joe they
really kind of blackmailed him into uh
pursuing what is going on with Joe where
he's gone to and so on and so forth now
the way they do this is really by
telling Wonder Man that the history that
Wonder Man has is that he's really kind
of been embezzling money from charities
and she was willing to make it go away
as long as Wonder Man will do what they
asked and the comic really kind of comes
to an end where we see the Wonder man's
hands are more or less tied here that
unless he wants to face criminal charges
for embezzlement that he is actually
going to have to act on behalf of shield
now while this isn't necessarily the
most interesting part of the civil war
event while it's not necessarily the
most action-packed it is one of the most
important and the reason why is because
initially the idea was that shield was
going to work with superheroes that the
the superhero community that was
registered and shield and the federal
government were really going to kind of
collaborate with each other but what we
see is that shield is really kind of
doing things the way they want to do it
they're really kind of doing things
their own way and that either
superheroes can collaborate or they can
face the possibility of being sent to
the negative zone and this is a very
important aspect of the events of civil
war as we begin to move forward with the
story
so miss marvel issue number six is a
very well-put-together comic book and in
fact miss marvel is one of the premier
superheroes in Marvel Comics which is
really kind of ironic because we've
never really talked about her we've
never really had an in-depth marvel
explained video about Miss Marvel which
is of course something that we will do
but what's really kind of interesting
about Miss Marvel is despite the fact
that she's as powerful as she is that
she has effectively all the powers of
Superman more or less in Marvel Comics
that she has flight she has super
strength she has super speed she has
durability and all our different kind of
stuff she's a character who's very
complicated she's a character that's
always really kind of kind of looking
for acceptance she's always really kind
of looking for a way to establish
herself as more than just kind of a
sidekick to somebody else and this was
really kind of interesting when we saw
her in the Avengers but what we see as
far as the Civil War event is that she
is staunchly on the side of Iron Man she
really isn't one of these individuals
that kind of wavers and is kind of
unsure whether or not she's doing the
right thing while she does she's not
necessarily like militant in the sense
that she is kind of imposing her will on
people but she's one of these
individuals that believes that it's
ultimately going for the greater good
now as the story really kind of unfolds
what we're gonna see going on here what
we're going to see kind of progressing
is that not everyone who is against the
superhuman Registration Act is openly
against it what I mean here is that
there are some individuals who are
working against Iron Man while
pretending to be part of iron man's
group and as the story begins to unfold
we see that Miss Marvel and shield are
attempting to track down a superhero
named Prowler
now Prowler is really kind of kind of
interesting a Hobie Brown is one of
these superheroes that isn't necessarily
inherently powerful me.they doesn't
really have any powers of his own he
actually uses technology to really kind
of enhance himself to really kind of
make himself a superhero and what we see
is that Miss Marvel and shield are able
to successfully capture him and they
take him back to Rikers Island for
interrogation now one of the things that
I really enjoy about these comics is
that Marvel is really kind of put in
here more or less kind of an ability or
the the
chance for us to look at these
characters and to see what their
inherent powers are what kind of aliases
they've had and what stance they take
with regards to superhuman Registration
and this I think is a very important
thing because as the Marvel Civil War
event really kind of progresses unless
you're paying very close attention or
unless we're doing something like we are
here where we're kind of explaining the
events as they as they progress you
might really kind of find yourself
getting lost you might really kind of
find yourself being shuffled around and
not really sure who stands for what or
which side anybody is on and so Marvel
is really kind of giving this
information albeit it's really kind of
confined to the characters in this comic
book and what we see as we continue
along with this story is that Marvel I'm
sorry Wonder Man meets with Carol
Danvers as they are going to be heading
to stark tower and that they're actually
kind of running late and as they get to
start tower we see that Julia carpenter
who is one of the many women in Marvel
Comics that will play the role of Spider
Woman is a meeting with them and really
kind of I guess letting them know that
spider-man himself is running late
spider-man
I'm sorry Iron Man is is running late
Iron Man finally arrives and he really
is kind of dishing out orders to people
as these individuals are part of the
superhero recovery team their roles are
exactly what it sounds like their job is
to go around with shield and to capture
individuals who refuse to register and
what we see is of course he's really
kind of applauding them that they have
successfully been able to catch the
Prowler and we really kind of see Iron
Man stating that Captain America's
actions with regards to going
underground his guerrilla warfare
tactics again shield and iron man have
really kind of spurred people on and
have really kind of given those
individuals who have chosen not to
register kind of a rallying person so
that they can really kind of make their
own plans and hopefully come into
contact with Captain America at some
point in time which is something that
Ironman is trying to keep from happening
one of the things that he assigns to
Miss Marvel and to Wonder Man is to
capture someone named araña now we don't
really know who or Anya is as far as
these particular comics we know that our
Anya at some point played the role of
Spider Girl
but between 2004 2005 when she made an
appearance and now
we don't really know what she's doing I
mean she had a 12 issue limited run but
for the most part she was a very obscure
character in Marvel Comics to a degree
we really didn't see her pop up a whole
lot and Ironman goes as far as to say
this he says that they have an idea of
where she's operating from they have an
idea of what it is that she's doing but
they don't really know anything about
her they don't know what physical form
she may take on aside from the kind of
insect form that we see in the the
hologram that he's presenting to them
now as far as Julia carpenter he assigns
her the role of capturing max Coolidge
and max Coolidge goes by the name of
shroud and he's able to use some kind of
dark energy I believe to really kind of
aid him while he's combating people and
what we see is the comic really kind of
continues is that Iron Man pulls Carol
Danvers aside pulls Miss Marvel aside
and begins to ask her about Captain
America about whether or not Captain
America had ever caught ever tried to
contact her at this point we really kind
of jumped back to a meeting that had
taken place between Captain America and
Carol Danvers and Captain America is
really kind of talking to her about how
the law is unjust and he's not
necessarily going as far as to say I
want you on my side although we know
that that really is the case that Miss
Marvel would be an excellent Ally for
anyone to have but he's really kind of
kind of making an argument to her that
what's going on here just isn't really
fair but Miss Marvel goes as far as to
say that the country is based on the
idea of laws and whether or not the laws
are right or wrong you have to follow
them
just because you disagree with the law
doesn't mean it gives you the right to
break it if you disagree with the law
you should go through the political
process of trying to get the law changed
from there we jump back to Carol Danvers
as she's speaking with Tony Stark and
she says that she doesn't really know
where Captain America is she doesn't
really know what it is that he's doing
which for the most part is a true
statement now we see that she eventually
meets up with Wonder Man and the two of
them begin their assignment of
attempting to capture her Anya now from
there we switch to Rikers Island and we
see that a SHIELD agent is interrogating
Hobie Brown Prowler and what's really
kind of interesting here is this is one
begin to see that not everyone who is
trying to defeat the superhuman
Registration Act is doing so in the same
fashion as
in America we see that this individual
is kind of interrogating Hobie Brown and
what we see is that he's talking he
really kind of brings up the idea that
someone tipped Hobie Brown off someone
told him that that the shield was going
to be coming for him and that they had
arrived in his apartment about five
minutes after he had left fully in
disguise and he really kind of hounds
them he really kind of pushes towards
him he really kind of pulls out every
stop in order to draw this information
from him he goes as far as to say that
it'll drop him into a hole he'll never
see the light of day again they'll take
his family away so on and so forth and
finally Hobie Brown admits to the person
that gave him the information that
tipped him off and what we see is that
this person is Julia carpenter now from
there we switched to Julia carpenter
who's meeting with max Coleridge and
she's really kind of trying to tell max
Coleridge that shield is going to come
after them that she is the one that's
supposed to capture him and that if she
doesn't bring them in then her her cover
is really going to kind of be blown that
she was going to be aware of the fact
that she is more or less kind of a
double agent so to speak and what we see
is that Hobie Brown is not okay I'm
sorry that a match Coolidge is not okay
with this the match Coolidge is he's
really kind of against the idea of of
Julia carpenter I guess both maybe
revealing her identity and really kind
of taking a stance that would put her in
peril and so he tells her you need to
take me in now Julia carpenter is avidly
against this Julia carpenter really
doesn't want to have to take max in it
max really kind of tries to rationalize
with her and say that you have a
daughter you have more concern you have
more to worry about than I do but
ultimately we see that Julia carpenter
turns against shield from this point
moving forward Julia carpenter is now a
fugitive and she is branded that way by
the shield files on her as an individual
from here we transition back to Miss
Marvel and Wonder Man and we see that
they're really kind of hunting around
they're really kind of looking for a
roni other in the general vicinity from
where she's acting but they don't really
know where to find her at they come
across a restaurant called chicken cow I
believe and I'm not really sure what
kind of a restaurant this is supposed to
be a play on but I would most likely say
it's like a KFC or a chick-fil-a or
something like that but we see some
witty banter between the two of them we
see
miss Marvel says she hasn't eaten here
in quite some time and Wonder Man is a
little flirty when he says he's kind of
amazed that she's able to keep her
figure despite the fact that she eats
food like this
from here we switched to the events that
are going on inside the restaurant for
the most part it doesn't really seem too
crazy it really kind of seems like some
a really slow moment in the comic and
we're really kind of expecting something
more to happen and something actually
does what we see is that a group of
thieves break into the place and they
begin to try the process of robbing it
and we see one of them point a gun at
Miss Marvel and she kind of laughed this
off because as we know Miss Marvel would
not be affected by a bullet in addition
we see that one of the individuals
really kind of begins to manifest
themselves they really kind of begin to
present themselves as a superhero of
sorts although trying their best to keep
it under control
Miss Marvel and Wonder Man are able to
defeat the criminals with the slightest
of ease and then we see this individual
break out and ask them is there anybody
that wants a piece of them and then
that's when it's revealed to us that
this is in fact the person they've been
looking for the entire time